SMRITI PRAMANICK: My
name is Smriti Pramanick,
and today, I'd love to
tell you a little bit more
about what I've been
working on this past year.
So if you've ever been
to a classical concert,
you're probably familiar
with a music program.
It's usually paper and includes
the pieces that will be played,
the composer, and maybe
some background info.
The lab I'm working with, The
Music Technology Lab at MIT,
is trying to revolutionize
the concert-going experience
and provide a new interactive
program called ConcertCue.
So what happens is a
concert concertgoer
is listening to the
piece and provided
relevant pieces of information
as the piece progresses.
So in the beginning, they
might receive some background
information, and then
halfway through the piece,
they might get their attention
drawn to some repeating melody,
or be informed that some
trumpet section is coming up.
So the way this
works is a technique
called audio
synchronization where
we have a reference recording
in the database, which
has been annotated with beats
and relevant information.
And currently, a human operator
that sits there and taps
out the beats, in
the live setting.
So my project focused on
automating this process
and figuring out how we can take
in the live audio in a concert
setting and have the computer
tell us which beat we're on.
So there are a couple
of different approaches
to this problem.
And they all involve
online variants
of a audio
synchronization algorithm
called dynamic time warping.
So I surveyed many
of these algorithms
and decided to implement them.
They were mostly theoretical
before, so implementing them
was a lot of fun and took
some work to actually make
it work in a live setting.
And then I got the
opportunity to try out
one of these algorithms at
the Boston Symphony Orchestra
a couple of weeks ago, with
very promising results.
Essentially, the beat that
the computer predicted
we were on in the life
piece matched perfectly
with the human operator.
So it looks like this
will be able to work well
with the application.
And I look forward to seeing
that integration happen.